should Americans lose their citizenship
if they burn the flag Donald Trump think
so early tuesday morning at 355 a.m.
eastern standard time to be exact Donald
Trump tweeted this nobody should be
allowed to burn the American flag if
they do there must be consequences
perhaps loss of citizenship or year in
jail burning the flag may not scream
patriotism but it's totally legal in the
United States let me repeat that burning
the American flag is completely legal in
this country this issue was resolved
back in the 80s in 1984 gregory lee
johnson burned an american flag outside
the republican national convention in
dallas texas johnson was protesting
against the policies of President Ronald
Reagan's administration Texas officials
arrested tried and convicted Johnson of
breaking a state law that prohibited
desecration of the American flag Johnson
took his case to the Supreme Court
arguing that his actions were symbolic
speech protected by the First Amendment
and in 1989 the Supreme Court agreed
with him and here's the best part
Justice Antonin Scalia joined the
majority opinion in that case you know
the guy Trump has openly praised and
hopes to replace with another
conservative justice so president-elect
Donald Trump burning the flag is
protected by the First Amendment which
is found in that little thing called the
Constitution